okay
good afternoon it's been a while
for those of you who don't remember my
name is ned price i'm the spokesperson
here
um it's good to be back with you all uh
we have a
few items at the top starting with
bella bruce the united states has looked
to improve the tenor of our bilateral
relationship with belarus
that effort has received broad
bipartisan support
across administrations we still want to
see belarus succeed
as an independent prosperous democratic
country
however the events surrounding the
conduct of the fraudulent 2020
presidential election
the violent and repressive tactics in
its aftermath
and over 300 political prisoners cannot
be ignored many american officials have
conveyed these sentiments directly
to belarusian authorities since those
elections
in 2015 the department of treasury uh
uh issued and has since extended
annually a general license authorizing
transactions with nine
state-owned enterprises in belarus we
did this because of notable progress
at the time in the field of human rights
and specifically
due to the release of all political
prisoners
regrettably we find the human rights
situation
has deteriorated to arguably the worst
point in belarus's independent
history with more than 300 political
prisoners
currently detained in belarus the
department is unable to recommend
another extension at this time
particularly in light
of the sense of congress expressed in
the 2020 belarus
sovereignty and democracy act the
current extension will expire
on april 26th this step is reversible
and we call on belarusian authorities to
take
steps to allow us to do just that
specifically
by releasing all political prisoners the
lukashinka regime is still able to take
these necessary steps to reverse course
release
all those wrongfully imprisoned simply
for peacefully
disagreeing with the authorities
espousing different views
or daring to compete in an election
we call for the full and unconditional
release of all political prisoners
and the cessation of violence by the
authorities against
the belarusian people further we
continue
our call for the authorities to commit
to a meaningful dialogue
with the leaders of the political
opposition under the auspices of the
osce
leading to free and fair elections under
independent
observation the united states will
continue to support the belarusian
people
in their aspirations for a democratic
future
we'll we'll have a couple more we can
come back to it uh as you may have seen
in the secretary's recent statement the
department of state is required by law
to submit the hong kong policy act
report and accompanying certification to
congress
annually this year's report details the
actions taken by prc and hong kong
authorities
to further erode hong kong's high degree
of autonomy and freedoms
during the reporting period which
entailed june 2020 to february
of 2021. based on the report's findings
the secretary
has certified to congress that hong kong
does not
warrant treatment under u.s law in the
same manner as u.s laws were
applied to hong kong before july 1st of
1997
the date of course of the handover from
the uk to the prc
today therefore we submitted the hong
kong policy act report to congress
and certified for the second time that
hong kong does not warrant differential
treatment to the prc
under u.s law because of the prc and
hong kong actions
taken to dismantle hong kong's autonomy
we also want to take this opportunity to
strongly condemn
the actions taken on march 30th by the
prc national
people's congress standing committee to
further erode political participation
and representation in hong kong we are
also deeply concerned by the delay of
the september legislative council
elections
for the second time these changes to
hong kong's electoral system
defy the will of the people in hong kong
deny hong kongers a voice
in their own governance the changes
which will establish a committee to vet
candidates for office based solely on
their loyalty to beijing
and diminish the proportion of directly
elected members of the legislative
council
will severely curtail meaningful
pluralism and representative
governance in hong kong these changes
are inconsistent
with hong kong's basic law which states
that universal suffrage is the ultimate
objective
for the people in hong kong the united
states stands
uh united with our allies and partners
in speaking out
against the human rights and freedoms
speaking
out for the human rights and freedoms of
hong kongers and we call on the prc to
uphold its international obligations and
commitments under the sino-british joint
declaration
the voices of the people in hong kong
must be heard and the legislative
council elections should proceed
in a free and fair manner that allows
candidates to run for election
irrespective of their political views
moving on to syria yesterday u.s
ambassador to the united nations linda
thomas
greenfield represented the united states
at the fifth brussels conference
supporting the future of syria and the
region it was co-chaired by the european
union
and the united nations ambassador thomas
greenfield
announced more than 596 million dollars
in new humanitarian assistance
for the syria crisis response continuing
long-standing u.s leadership
and alleviating the suffering of
vulnerable people in line with both our
values the nation
and our national interests this brings
u.s humanitarian assistance to more than
13
billion dollars since the start of the
crisis this new assistance will help
some of the 13 million syrians who have
been forced out of their homes
fleeing the horrific effects of the
assad regime's vicious campaign of
unjust detention and violence
it will help those displaced inside
syria and those who sought refuge
in egypt iraq jordan lebanon and turkey
and support the generous communities
hosting them
the united states will continue to be a
leader in the humanitarian response
and to advocate for unhindered
humanitarian access to syrians
regardless of where they live
to that end we will work with the u.n
security council to renew and expand the
un's authorization for cross-border
access
to deliver humanitarian aid to syrians
in need i'm sure many of you
uh heard secretary lincoln's impassioned
plea
during the u.n security council session
uh the other day to do just that
in other in other news yesterday the
united states and cabo verde
participated in our third
bilateral partnership dialogue
reaffirming cooperation between our two
countries that will strengthen our
economic ties
expand expand our educational exchanges
and further enhance
our security coordination the united
states is proud of its long friendship
with cabo verde which is a model of
human rights and democracy
and we deeply value our rich history of
relations over the past
two centuries as yesterday's partnership
dialogue underscored we will continue
to closely work with cabo verde to
expand trade and investment in
cooperation on security
telecommunications networks as well as
pressing challenges including recovering
from the pandemic confronting the
climate crisis
and improving maritime security
focusing on the global pandemic for a
moment the u.s announced on monday
that the u.s government will co-host a
vaccine alliance event with goth
our partner in cobax which is working to
provide coveted 19 vaccines to 92
low and middle-income countries in
february president biden announced the
united states providing an initial 2
billion
out of a planned 4 billion dollars to
kovacs
this event will bring together world
leaders the private sector and partners
from around the world to mobilize
additional resources
and commitments needed to end the
pandemic
secretary of state blinken u.s acting
administrators administrator gloria
steele
and gabby board chair jose manuel
barroso will all deliver remarks
while we continue to distribute vaccines
for americans as quickly as we can
it is also imperative that we contain
the global spread of coven 19
and emerging variants we must win the
race between getting all of humanity
vaccinated
and the emergence of new and even more
dangerous variants
that have the potential to threaten us
all while the us through usaid
is the world's largest donor it's a
global covenant
kova 19 vaccination effort no nation can
act alone
in a global pandemic and that includes
united states equitable access to
vaccines is critical to reduce the
tragic loss of life
in the pandemic recover the us and the
global economy
and keep americans safe and finally
in recognition of transgender day of
visibility the united states stands with
the international community to celebrate
the courage and resilience of
transgender and gender non-conforming
persons around the world
and to acknowledge their efforts to
achieve equality and justice
in the face of adversity the united
states is committed to continuing to
advance human rights and fundamental
freedoms around the world
we call on all governments to honor
their commitments under the universal
declaration of human rights
to promote and protect the human rights
of all individuals
which of course includes lesbian gay
bisexual transgender queer
and intersex uh intersex persons
with that was close to a record
number of toppers six almost nine
minutes anyway
um so i've got two very brief ones in
the middle east but i want to start with
belarus because i have some
very quick questions about your opening
on that um one you said that
these nine state-owned businesses are
basically at risk of losing their
authorization
is there any indication that they have
taken advantage of
the authorization since it was i mean
what do they stand to lose here
do you know or did you find out secondly
you said that the department
at the moment is unable to recommend an
another extension of this
isn't it the case that this is a
treasury decision so secretary yellen
could basically say
yeah well that's a nice recommendation
but i don't agree with it right
and then do it anyway and then lastly i
just wanted to find out what's the
status of the
ambassador who's been kind of bouncing
around
well you're referring to ambassador
julie fisher as you know she continues
to be on our ambassador to belarus to uh
represent
our interests and our values when it
comes uh to uh
the challenges in belarus when it comes
to america's support for the people of
belarus who are
standing firm against the repression of
the lukashinka government
she has traveled in the region she was
in europe i believe it was uh just last
month meeting with some of our allies
and partners
uh to explore um
and to coordinate um our collective
action to support uh
and collective efforts i should say to
support uh the people
of uh belarus and so she continues to do
that important work when it comes to the
general license
there's no progress in actually getting
her convinced she is
she is uh not immense she is she is
based here at the moment
uh when it comes to the general uh
license uh
as i alluded to at the at the at the
outset uh this is in fact something that
we
hope does not come to pass uh we have
put forward as i said just a moment ago
uh various uh uh demands uh
that uh if uh they were to be met
um this would not go into effect uh and
in fact it is our hope
uh that we will be able to renew this
general license that before it is set to
expire on april 26th you're right
uh this is a treasury uh decision the
united
the department of state works closely uh
in all matters including uh this to
coordinate
um providing recommendations providing
input um
to that treasury decision
you you expect that this building's
recommendation would be accepted by
treasury right
well we work closely together with any
pushback we coordinate closely uh
together i know when it comes to
supporting the people of belarus
um uh supporting their aspirations uh
for
uh democracy um we've worked incredibly
closely together not only with treasury
but also
uh with our partners throughout i can
either do the two brief mid-east ones
now or i can wait for them
uh let's let's come back to that um sean
i'll go in the middle east if you don't
mind um following up with yesterday i
know you had an entire briefing
yesterday on the human rights report but
on the question of occupation
uh there's been quite a bit of attention
to that that the u.s didn't use occupied
territories but the state department
didn't
in the uh report uh does this advocate
any type of permanent change in policy
is this a continuation of the
policy of the trump administration um
how do you uh
well i addressed this from the podium uh
several weeks ago
now what i said then uh of course
remains true today and that
is uh it is a historical fact uh that
israel occupied the west bank
gaza and the golan heights after the
1967
war you mentioned the human rights
report that we rolled out yesterday in
fact the 2020 human rights report
does use the term occupation in the
context of the current status
of the west bank this has been the
long-standing position
of previous administrations of both
parties over the course
of many decades uh to follow up on that
what were the implications for use
policy does the us consider for example
uh israeli settlements in the upcoming
territories to be illegal as
this doesn't change uh our position
uh we as you have heard me say before we
uh continue to encourage all sides to
avoid actions both sides i should say to
avoid actions that would put
the two-state solution further out of
reach again our ultimate goal here
uh is to facilitate uh to help uh bring
about
a two-state solution because uh it is
the best path to preserve
israel's identity as a jewish and
democratic state while bestowing on the
palestinians
their legitimate aspirations of uh
sovereignty
and dignity in the state of their own
on assistance to the palestinians
there's been some reports on that but i
know you had a statement
last week on covet assistance um
palestinians
keep an update on what the total